a flood of new call of duty info some
exciting fighting game surprises and
more on today's gamespot news
at this past weekend's call of duty
league world championship gratz la
thieves infinity ward announced dates
for the modern warfare 2 upcoming beta
the beta will start on september 16th
and 17th for playstation players via
early access anyone on that platform
that pre-orders the game received a beta
code during the world championship event
or receives them via online giveaways
from activision or partnered streamers
will have access at this time on the
18th through the 20th of september the
beta becomes open to all playstation
players gamers on xbox and pc can jump
into their own early access period on
september 22nd and 23rd with the beta
becoming available to all players on
every platform september 24th through
26th that means if you're playing in
early access on playstation you have a
full 10 days of beta to sink your teeth
into no merge were confirmed for the
beta but a new map marina grand prix
which looks to take place on a formula 1
race track was shown off and will be
playable in september but that's not all
right before the beta kicks off on
september 15th call of duty next event
will take place this will be when you
will get your first real look at modern
warfare 2's multiplayer activision's
next iteration of war zone as well as a
taste of war zone for mobile yes call of
duty currently has a very popular mobile
title that does already include a battle
royale mode but it is something more
akin to the br that was packed in with
black ops 4 blackout than the much more
popular standalone warzone okay was that
enough call of duty for you i think that
was enough call of duty for you how
about some tekken that's right there's a
new tekken game incoming maybe well we
don't really know but there is something
tekken happening during this past
weekend's other big event evo 2022
publisher bandai namco dished out a
cryptic teaser that showed series
regular kazuya mishima presented in his
classic pixelated form dropping a body
off the edge of a cliff he then smiles
at the camera as the graphics morph into
something much more impressive as text
appears on screen that says get ready
the teaser has some fans believing the
next tekken will be a reboot but nothing
is confirmed as of yet and again to be
clear there is no confirmation that this
was even a teaser for a new game at all
the tekken tease was the tip of the
iceberg for fighting game reveals at evo
including new characters being added to
guilty gear strive new character
announcements for street fighter 6 and a
whole slew of fighting games getting
rollback netcode all the additional
details on gamespot.com if you've been
itching for more splatoon 3 news you're
in luck the game is getting a nintendo
direct focused on it this wednesday
august 10th revealing quote roughly 30
minutes of updates about the latest game
in the team-based shooter franchise
which hasn't seen a new trailer since
the release date was revealed back in
april we already know a lot about
splatoon 3 including the return of two
classic splatoon game modes the 4v4 turf
war and the co-op salmon run the game
will also feature new stages set in the
quote splatlands the wild areas that
surround incopolis as well as a story
mode called return of the mammalians and
that is it for today's gamespot news are
you planning to check out call of duty
modern warfare 2's of beta let us know
in the comments below and we'll see you
right here tomorrow on gamespot
[Music]